first talk to me my collection and
there's a long list of co-authors on one
of them small disclaimer I was involved
in the beginning of this but then the
other guys keep our core part recipe by
other guys took it to higher heights
something moving out for I guess the
full title that I gave crows or sorting
and geometric geometric algorithms yeah
that's a good volume I guess so thanks
for the opportunity to to come speak
it's been it's been a great workshop so
far yeah so this was that I was told
once that that the polite way to refer
to something old was to say that it was
classical so in that sense at least this
is pretty classical work I mean some of
you may have been in high school when
this was done I'm not completely sure so
it was joint work with a number of
people at who were at the time at
Princeton and also myself and sesh was
summer intern at IBM and then a postdoc
at IBM and some of the work was done
when he was when he was there so this is
three papers the first of which did not
involve me the second and which did and
and the third was me and sesh and
Wolfgang wolf calm so this isn't too is
a little bit redundant in view of some
of the earlier talks and actually might
be stealing a little bit from the next
talk but just to just to set the
notation and to put it into context a
context we did not actually use at the
time you can think of you can put
self-improving algorithms in the context
of machine learning where and
specifically in the context of risk
minimization so there is given some
distribution d and you have some
training samples from that distribution
there's a concept space see there's a
loss function that takes a concept
and an instance of the random variable
distributed as d and produces some real
value and then the risk of the concept
see is the expected loss for 4c okay so
the goal is to use the samples ZK to
somehow find a good concept to find a
concept that has minimum risk so that
the classical version of this is
classification so you're given also a
label function f of z and the the
concept class is a set of functions on z
and the loss is the expense if the given
function c doesn't agree on z with with
f so f c of Z is not equal to F of Z so
so that's either some cost maybe a unit
cost for for disagreeing and a zero cost
for agreeing so so then you you use the
training samples you find a good
classifier that most of the time gives
you agreement with the with the given
function okay so here there is also a
function f of z hello
weird where did I go
I stuck no no it's hdmi so did I step on
something
ignore the man behind the curtain so I
can well so so without the slides there
there's a there's also given a function
f and the the situation for us for
self-improving algorithms is that there
without the slides for you guys at any
right there is a set of algorithms whose
output always agrees with the function
so you use the algorithms to compute the
function it's it's there you restrict
yourself to algorithms that are actually
correct and the loss is not the
disagreement with the with the function
it's the it's the running time of the
algorithm so so this is a learning to
run fast problem so i think i should
play around with something here at least
20 rebooting the system great well I was
telling to somebody yesterday about
progress bars and how how they were
difficult to implement but we'll see how
how realistic this is so it's cliff
Stein here no okay no I wanted to take
the opportunity to insult cliff Stein
but I guess I I can't do it what even
better time yeah so cliff you sit on a
throne of lies that's so I just because
in his talk for those of you who he he
insulted the organizers I don't know he
it's engaged in random insulting
behavior so
hey please ensure that your it's all
Paul do that again oh yeah did Ice cut
okay that's one of them okay so so I
think the difficulty probably is that I
stepped on hdmi cable which where the
other thing doesn't get this rib it yeah
cliffs revenge okay so it will come up
in the center okay okay right in the
meantime yeah so so that was like 20
minutes that that took so I'll have okay
so so self-improving algorithms is is
doing machine learning but as a purim
said as nikka said mentioned also or
talked about actually it's it's not for
the purpose of training a classifier if
it's for some other performance measure
and in our case it's for running time
okay so how do you use these training
samples effectively in the in the
classification setting you basically use
the training samples as a proxy for the
the distribution you use the average
over the law of the average of the loss
over them as an approximation to the
expected loss so that can be helpful and
I think the next talk actually actually
makes serious progress on discount on
that kind of approach but kind of on
some generic level this first of all
might be very hard because what's the
what's the optimization procedure for as
the space of algorithms and second if
you strictly try to do as best you can
on the training samples that's probably
going to be taped table lookup as the
fastest possible way to to run on the
training samples so in that sense you
you might be over training okay so the
strategy here going back to to ten years
work worked it included near is to
instead not use empirical risk
minimization but to find a lower bound
on the best possible running time you
know find what the the value of the
minimum risk can be
and then construct an algorithm that
provably achieves that minimum risk up
to a constant factor so a certain amount
of the of the question here of the of
the work year is just to find the right
conditions on the concept class see the
set of algorithms and on the probability
distribution of the inputs that will
make this kind of approach possible so
what was looked at in the course of
these various papers was first of all
sorting second of all de l'année
triangulation so there's there's an
input set of points and then there is a
triangulation put on connecting all of
those points together and then the
convex hull of the set of points and as
I as I did by construction in this case
the the convex hull is actually a subset
of the de l'année triangulation and we
look in particular at the upper hull so
just the kind of the upper part of that
thing that the concave part of the
convex hull but easily its root you know
the full general case is reducible to
this of course and we also look at
coordinate wise maxima where a point is
dominated by another point point a is
dominated by point B if B is is up and
to the right from point A and so we're
looking for all the points that aren't
dominated so the the inputs to these
these tasks are either in the case of
sorting a set of sariah a vector
basically of real values or in the other
cases it's a vector of points in the
plane so it's an ordered list of these
of these input values so these are all
combinatorial problems their outputs are
all combinatorial it's the permutation
that gives something that sorted the
graph that that connects these these
vertices the sequence of points on the
upper convex hull or in sorted order or
the vertices in order of the convex hull
the upper convex hull or ever that's re
if the coordinate wise maxima now we
require a little bit more of our output
we require it actually to give us
certificates of
correctness that can be verified quickly
and so for for sorting and delaying
triangulations that's actually just the
the output itself can be used in linear
time to get a verification of
correctness but for the others it
requires a little bit more so in the
case of coordinate wise Maxima you not
only have the sequence of Maxima in
sorted order you also get for each point
that is dominated some witness point
that actually dominates it so then the
user of this computing service so to say
can can go through and and verify that
they got the correct output in in linear
time so this is mainly I guess a way of
getting into the the picture of the
output getting into the making explicit
the kinds of things that any correct
algorithm has to do implicitly so a
correct algorithm has to in effect
construct the proof of the correctness
of its output and this just makes that
more explicit and allows us to kind of
in a sense and get credit for it okay so
the the algorithms that we're going to
consider first of all polynomial space
let's say and and not too many training
samples and we want them to be correct
on all inputs even inputs that might in
this particular distribution have
probability zero so that pretty much
says that the work that we're going to
do has to be linear in the number of
input values or points and or at any
rate we're going to allow ourselves
event time and in these in these
algorithms in general so the main
restriction on what we do here is that
the key operations that we the
algorithms will do on the data are
comparisons so is this value greater
than that value is this point to the you
know above or below a given line that
kind of thing okay so looking at a
comparison based algorithms for one
thing it means that the algorithm is
determined by and this is one of the
conditions that we have if if it's not
already there really is
the output is determined by the sequence
of comparisons that are done in the
course of the algorithm so there's some
you can think of it as some bit string
come seek of cz that is the Sikh gives
you the sequence of comparisons done by
the algorithm see on the input Z so that
says that the work is going to be at
least linear in the input size and
linear in the number of comparisons and
will consider algorithms that basically
are are you know Oh of those those
quantities and we actually can allow a
pretty broad category pretty good
variety of possible comparisons although
I think in that we in some sense to do
some restrictions in the geometric
setting that we we use some fairly
natural ones that it's not i'm not sure
that we get handle a situation of
arbitrary input polynomial or arbitrary
polynomial that we then do a comparison
against so so since near and sesh are
here they can actually verify that that
that's a correct statement but yeah
isn't make sure I'm understanding okay
there's some probability distribution on
the inputs yeah and you get samples from
it I'm your objective is to get an
algorithm with the best for any time
possible in expectation yeah yeah the
same problem yeah yeah so that's but
that's exactly the risk minimization
problem yeah yeah yeah yeah no it's fine
yeah okay okay there's any any I'm not
sure when you can reconnect if I boss to
at this point but so so there were
conditions on the on the on the outputs
and now I'm have some conditions on the
on the algorithms the main one of which
is this thing of being comparison based
and the main sort of fact about being
comparison based that we use I think is
that a single comparison sort of by its
nature only gives you one bit of
information so sort of fairly trivial in
that sense but that does imply a kind of
lower bound on on running times so the
input is a random variable input Z's
around variability output F of Z is a
random variable and the f of z can be
constructed
constructed using the algorithm and the
sequence of comparisons that it does so
that says that the sequence of
comparisons using that sense and
encoding of of the output that could be
sent over a communication channel so by
Shannon's theorem via the expected
length of that sequence has to be larger
than the entropy of the output so so
there's a lower bound on the work that
is done by these algorithms which is
that they have to be linear in the input
size and also do work proportional to
the entropy of the output so you're
looking at me funny but ok ok ok so
there is a truly classical example of a
comparison based algorithm that that has
that kind of lower bound and therefore
and also has that kind of upper bound
which is entropy optimal search trees so
here there are some sorted lists of
values that are given and some function
which maps a given real value to let's
say the jade interval of that sorted
list that contains that value and for
each one of those are some probability
that that the real value will fall in
that interval and so there you know this
this quantity J the J interval f of Z
has an entropy and we any any comparison
based algorithm has to do work basically
proportional to that entropy and of
course this is satisfied by by entropy
optimal search trees as and Kurt milhorn
in 1975 showed how to find them
efficiently for a given for a given
input so here's here's kind of a
prototypical you know entropy optimal
algorithm where the lower bound is is
the entropy of the output in the upper
bound is can be can be achieved by a
certain class of search tree okay
finally I think conditions on the
distribution of the inputs and this is
this is a maybe one of the more
questionable or or difficult
restrictions which is that we require
each of the input quantities so a given
input instance is is some Z but Z is a
sequence of values or points x 1 up to
xn we require that X I have its own
private probability distribution and the
probability of and that it's independent
of the other xxi prime okay so so you
have x1 you know in the first instance
that x1 is generated in some random way
in the next instance x1 is generated in
the same random way and so on and so
forth so this is maybe it sounds a
little funny from from some more general
point of view but it is a fairly feral
yet it's fairly natural and yet at the
same time it's maybe more restrictive
than we would really like but one thing
is that these distributions don't have
to be identical they don't have to be
known they don't have to be discrete or
continuous they can they can be really
quite arbitrary up to the fact that we
have this independence okay and the
basic reason for this restriction is
that if we don't have it then in some
there's there's families of
distributions such that we can't have a
running time which meets the the entropy
lower bound unless we use exponential
storage okay so essentially there's just
there's too many possible different
probability distributions that might
that we might have to look at if we
don't restrict ourselves to two
independent to product distributions and
among all of those there there can't be
too many different algorithms where the
specification of the algorithm includes
the the bits that are stored for the
algorithm so it's just a a counting
argument that leads to this lower bound
okay so so what was actually done in
this work given all of these various
conditions we do in find a
algorithms that with the exception of
convex hull do this this optimal work oh
you know linear in the input size and in
the output entropy they take quadratic
training instances in score training
instances and N squared storage it's not
quite as bad as that in terms of the
training instances in storage there's a
nice trade-off that for any Alpha you
can you can have into the 1 plus alpha
training instances and storage and pay a
constant factor of 1 over alpha in the
work that you do for that purpose you
know for in that in that setting so so
you know if alpha is is one-tenth then
you're doing 10 times the work but
suddenly I mean now your space and and
your training samples are really a
little more you know quite plausibly
manageable yeah sorry I'm not so
familiar with entropy but if its product
distributions and let's say they're I ID
then the dependence on n in entropy will
only be just some of into back I mean
just a product of independent
distributions right so so so there's
yeah I mean this is a DI depend on it or
they allowed to defend all right no no
no so it would there there will be cases
where we just add up the entropy zuv
quantities and get the entropy of some
joint distribution because we know that
we have independence you would only get
an end there linear and I mean their IDs
you just kidding yeah yeah please put is
a permutation let's see a sorting
factorial option I see you thank you
okay no that's fine okay so there is
also a sort of county-based extension of
the the of the other lower bound which
shows that this trade-off is tight okay
so so there were the conditions there
were the basic general category of
results now I'll talk a little bit about
how this was actually done in the in the
relatively simple case of sorting so the
sorting algorithm does some
pre-processing using the training data
in in which a first step of it is to get
a set of set V of typical values and to
get the typical values it just takes
some lambda training samples where
lambda is about log n takes the union of
them sorts that and then picks off every
lambda one of those of those things in
sorted order let's see maybe I should
sure the picture so so VI is w sub
lambda I where w is the sorted list of
this sorted version of this union okay
so so V it should hopefully is
relatively relatively plausible to see
represents kind of the overall
distribution of this random variable Z
which is now a sequence of real values
and by this construction we expect in a
given interval between one member VJ of
the typical set and the next member VJ
plus 1 we expect about one input point
from from some one of these you know
from x 1 up to xn about one of those
guys will fall into into that interval
by construction so it has you know one
over n of the total probability mass
over all of these all of these
distributions okay so in addition to
this single typical set we also
construct for each for each input you
know x 1 up to xn we construct an
entropy optimal search tree as as
discussed earlier and here we the
particular notation would be that the
there's a random variable associated
with a search done for each each I which
is sort of the bucket index the the end
of the index of the interval containing
X I so if that's some J then that that
is the the goes into a variable bi which
it just holds that index so by by the by
the properties of entropy optimal search
trees the search costs for for a given I
is going to be
about 1 plus the entropy of this of the
search costs random variable bi and and
so that's that sort of is the complete
construction except in the sense that
you have to you have to bring in a lot
more training instances in order to
accurately be able to build a TI ya to
these buckets are kind of designs that
you expect in a typical instance roughly
one guy per bucket yeah yeah yeah okay
so the algorithm then is just to you
know for each one of the X I to do a
search for it to find what bucket
contains it using the search tree for it
and then for each bucket to just sort
the values that fall in that bucket and
and as ever point out yeah you expect
about one on a constant number of points
in that bucket and in fact even if you
look at the square of that you still
have a constant so the total work
overall is is linear for for that part
of the processing so so the main cost
here in many situations would be the the
cost of all of those searches that are
done and now so the searches are entropy
optimal so we're being very adaptive so
it sounds like okay that's that should
pretty much do the job but that's not
actually the case it hasn't been shown
that overall the total work that is done
has something to do with the entropy of
the output so it remains to show that
the the sum of the work done for the
entry entropy optimal search trees is is
is o of n plus plus the entropy yeah
yeah the entropy of the distribution
over the buckets oh yes the I element of
the earth element yeah yeah so that's a
that's a random variable and it has an
entrepreneur night it could be yeah yeah
just one could be could be 0 or yeah
more or less yeah so that's so the one
is there just to you know cover cover
that possibility of a constant so so the
independence now is used to just say
that the the sum of these these
individual entropies is going to be
o of n plus the entropy of the the Joint
Distribution of all of those bucket
indices so you have a vector B 1 up to
BN and you can look at its entropy as a
unit and just by the independence
that'll that that quantity will be equal
to the sum of the entropy zuv the of the
bucket per bucket and trapeze okay so
the reason why it's useful to think in
terms of this this vector B is that we
can actually compute that bucket vector
from the output okay so and using using
a linear number of additional
comparisons so how do we do that well we
sort of the the output is a permutation
that gives us the sorted order of the
inputs so we use the output to construct
the sorted order of the inputs we do a
merge of that sorted list with the
sorted list of V and that say that that
merge will take over n comparisons and
then we read off the bucket assignments
from the from that merged list so the
the output F F sub s of Z which is this
permutation allows us to to find what B
is so that says that be can be encoded
using an encoding of the output plus 0
of an additional bits and that means by
again applying Shannon that the search
work which is bounded by n plus 0 of n
plus that that entropy of the that big
vector will be equal to 0 of n plus the
entropy of the output so so again a
coding argument gives a way of giving an
analysis of this algorithm okay so I
guess all
or yeah at least you know so okay I
don't know okay so five minutes list for
your coffee thing Oh coffee okay I see I
see oh yeah so okay so that was sorting
and but at some point session I talked
about de l'année triangulations and
which are sort of sorting plus plus you
know in the sense that you know the the
de l'année triangulation of set of
points on a line actually gives you
their sorted order so if you can compute
the lani triangulations you can sort it
also has various other kind of natural
analogous you know connections one so so
one way to define adeline a
triangulation is that you you look at a
given triangle whose vertices are from
your your input and you look at its
circumscribed disc and if no other about
no points of the input are in the
interior of that disc then it's a de
l'année disc and the triangle is a de
l'année triangle and the de l'année
triangulation is just all of the all of
the de l'année triangles right and this
is assuming appropriate general position
kind of things so that life doesn't get
too messy so so that's what it is up to
the unbounded case where the de l'année
disks are just sort of the unbounded
things come from half planes which come
from could be regarded as disks with
points at infinity so so there is a kind
of another kind of analogy here that
that in sorting you're looking for
collections of input intervals on your
input that are empty of other values in
your input into lining triangulation
you're looking at these de l'année discs
which are again defined by a small
number of points of your input and are
empty in this certain sense so it turns
out that not only it is this kind of
analogy hold but the the actual
algorithm that we came up with is
actually step-by-step pretty much the
same as the algorithm for
storage for sorting sorry except that
we're certain steps in the algorithm for
sorting are just you know completely
trivial you know you merge these two
sets of sorted values you take a sorted
set and you pick out sorted subset of it
various of those operations which are
completely trivial in a sorting case
then we just we fortunately in all cases
we could like refer to somebody soda
paper for how to actually do that
operation so maybe one of the more
interesting aspects is the the typical
set V which was constructed by this
merger of some number of of inputs use
in in the de'longhi triangulation case
they something's pretty much analogous
which is a range space epsilon net using
where the ranges are discs where and
where epsilon is one over N and the size
of the of the net is 0 of n which is
which is a little better than then the
most obvious randomized constructions
give you so so instead of it instead of
this sort of typical set there's a
typical set which is a range space
epsilon net even in the analysis as I
guess I mentioned so so where there's
there's a step in the analogy analysis
in which you do this merge sort or you
do this merge of two sorted lists which
is really easy in the case of de l'année
triangulations that says here's two de
l'année triangulations and they're kind
of nicely related to each other but they
are kind of just distinct de l'année
triangulations somehow merge these
things together in linear time and this
is something I at least I certainly
don't remember specifically but Bernard
showed in 1992 how to do that so so
every one of the steps and sorting has a
corresponding thing into lonnie
triangulation which is much harder but
which is is doable so so there was at
the first work on sorting then some work
on de l'année triangulations and then a
session I talked about the possibility
of doing what should you know is
actually in general as that
most trivial geometric the most trivial
problem that you could call geometric
which is planar convex hulls and sort of
agreed that it ought to be doable and
this work is kind of the the maximum I
think of the of the number of times that
in the course of it somebody said the
equivalent of this really ought to be
doable because it was it was actually
surprisingly difficult to to get to work
including and are incomplete shall we
say soda paper claiming an optimal
algorithm but where we can only really
get an N log log n plus plus entropy of
the output now sir so so why why is this
hard so one way to express that I guess
is is that what you have to do is to
figure out how to account for the work
that you do for the points not that are
that are not in the output but for which
you proven cannot be in the output so so
some of those points will have a really
simple proof that they're not in the
output and others of those points will
have it will be harder to prove and you
don't know in advance which one's those
will be if you if you knew the the upper
hole of the point set beforehand then it
would be pretty easy to find those
proofs but of course you don't know that
so how do you kind of trade-off between
trying to find who's in the upper hall
and proving that you you don't have
things and you know that the given
points are not in the in the upper hall
or not on the core not part of the
coordinate wise maximum okay so we have
a few examples of kind of the funny
things that can happen suppose you have
you know half your points are our
constant there there's singleton
distributions they're just some fixed
points x 1 up to xn over to that form an
upper hull and then the remaining points
are each one of course is chosen
independently but they're chosen
independently to go in one of n over 2
maybe I can use the cursor one of these
n over two points here so ball classical
balls into bins roughly speaking you
have a a random permutation just below
the cut this this upper hall okay so
because of that because of this
situation there's a there's an easy
proof that all of those points although
that second half of the point set is not
in the upper hall namely they're all
below this line segment from x 1 up to X
n over 2 so you shouldn't do any really
you should do constant work for each one
of those points because there really is
a quick proof that that they are that
they're not on the on the upper hull and
and this is also an example of so you
know output sensitive algorithms which
take n times the log of the of the hole
size they don't you know they're just n
log n here there are instance optimal
order oblivious convex hull algorithms
where you're given the the points as a
set and you don't have even in the sense
that we have a kind of sorted order on
them you know what points don't have an
individual identity as they do for us
and you don't do any pre processing or
storage those also would take n log n
time for for this case randomized
incremental algorithms would take n log
n for this case and so on so this is a
particular point set where you know in
our risk you know a running time
minimization risk minimization framework
it should be easy and in fact it you
know and so we somehow have to make sure
that we don't do any kind of extra work
and sorting on those on those bottom
half points on the other hand in this
case where those bottom half points are
now distributed just below we do have to
do a lot more work so it should cost us
more to deal with this yes right in
order for the n log log in additional
term to make it not optimal the output
entropy must be smaller than any log log
n yeah which means the distributions be
such that the convex hull is constant
number of you a few points not the full
sort of endpoints well so we're
including we're including in the output
these these these certificates these
witnesses and even the the convex hull
side it could be a triangle and yet it
could be hard to prove for all it for
the remaining points I mean it could be
hard to find the proof that the
remaining points are are not in the
convex also it's hard to say exactly
maybe that's maybe that's not quite the
right example but I mean there it's not
simply a function of the number of
points of the convex hull because there
is this additional output to give this
or certificate waiting out has a lot of
points on the convex hull this is this
case which is not I mean you can you can
have any kind of distribution a point
you could pick you know these are just
constant points you could pick constant
points however you wished so it's not
it's not only a function of that of the
output size or are they the number or
the output size is a little different
for us but it's not only a function of
the number of vertices the convex hull
or something like that if I can just add
I mean in this case the permutation of
the points of the output is fixed so the
entropy here is actually just constant
because there's only one possible output
even though the number of points is a
lot yeah order otherwise is fixed yeah
thank you yeah so I don't know if that
ding should be here or Bernard I don't
know okay so so another possibility as I
mentioned is that is that it could be on
the other hand that you have the same
fixed set of points on the hull and then
a collection of points that are just
below so for each one of those points
that are just below you actually have to
do a search to figure out where they are
so that you then have a proof that
they're not not in the Hall another sort
of funny thing that can happen as a
situation where you x1 has two possible
positions 50-50 chance of being in this
lower position or in this upper position
and ditto for X n over 2 and so there's
some the property of being a whole point
of a given point being a whole point
it's very much conditional on on just
what happens with those two points so
you you you know you this is actually
doesn't make a huge difference I mean
you have a constant probability that
they'll both be low so so
don't have to pay worry too much about
paying for the possibility that they're
both up but this just shows that it can
be hard to to quickly decide if
something is a whole point or not okay
so yeah I I feel like I want to say that
I don't have time but i'll try to try to
describe some idea for how the
algorithms from maxima and whole work
okay so they both build this same kind
of typical set except they're there the
typical set you know which is a
collection of values is the collection
of typical set for the projections of
the input on to the horizontal axis so
the x coordinates of these of these
excise and we oh and also is built as
these entropy optimal trees / / input
point so the strategy in both cases is
to do searches using the entropy optimal
search trees but only as far down as is
necessary for correctness so at some
point you might be at some point in the
tree you know you know the its
x-coordinate you know that's in some
large vertical slab but knowing that
it's in that large vertical slab is
enough to tell you maybe that it's not a
coordinate wise maximum that it's
dominated by something you've already
seen so yeah there's the picture you the
maximum algorithm does a sweep from
right to left maintaining the the maxima
as it goes and here's a case where you
would be able to kind of if you know
that this point is only in this range in
its x-coordinate due to a search that
you did with its search tree then you
can you can eliminate it because you
know that this maximum point is above
and to the right of that of that point
this point on the other hand you don't
know and the whole uses all of that and
more including a construction in which
you have a sort of canonical hole based
on the input based on the training
samples with the property that any
supporting line has a very few points
very little probability mass above it
it's a kind of a convex hull version of
the of the typical set
so concluding remarks so are our have a
snorting and triumph emoji if you can
see that which says that we we do like
that the results are pleasingly tight in
a lot of cases we do get you know
matching upper and lower bounds we have
tears of disappointment and relief and
the monks scream that there's there's
not enough bang for the buck here you
know so this was all in the service of
shaving a log factor so you know we
build these complicated data structures
we do this complicated stuff and we get
rid of a log factor in in in our
algorithm so so I I think that explains
partly why this work is classical that
and not doesn't have so many follow ups
although I guess it has more than I've
been where of that that you know in
particularly in these in these geometric
cases you're doing a lot of work for for
that it was interesting certainly for me
personally to to learn of and to some
degree to be involved in these coding
arguments and then there's that sort of
natural questions of can we can we
impose stronger conditions that make
life a little easier in terms of getting
these algorithms are there are broader
conditions that still allow us to get
some kind of interesting results so
that's it thanks for your attention
so while expectations I guess one thing
maybe it's the xbox what it's big heart
you really are using a very stringent
lower fam you really try to do the best
possible compared to anything at all so
as you get the things that are harder
and harder for algorithms you don't have
those kind of lower bounds of saying is
not possible at all to do but you know
so instead you maybe have to compare to
a family of algorithms or something of
that nature which is like I put the next
to tots we're going to both that's what
we're going to hear about next I guess